six months ago we were expecting a
shallow but long recession
since then Energy prices have fallen
substantially
and economic activity is holding up
better than expected
so today we are forecasting modest but
positive growth and a much smaller
increase in unemployment
we think inflation will fall quite
sharply over the coming months beginning
with the April number
which will be released in two weeks time
Energy prices have fallen from their
peaks
and that will now start to come through
as lower inflation
food price inflation should ease too
that we can be less sure about this on
timing
but let me be clear inflation remains
too high and it's our job to get it all
the way down to the two percent Target
and have it stay there
and this is why today we've increased
bank rate by 0.25 percentage points to
four and a half percent
low and stable inflation is the
foundation of a healthy economy and we
have to stay at the course to make sure
inflation Falls all the way back to the
two percent Market
in the Montreal policy report we present
today we've revised up our projections
for growth in the UK economy
in the central projection shown in chart
one here the UK economy grows at a
moderate Pace over the next three years
with calendar year growth expected to be
a quarter of a percent this year and
three quarters of a percent in 2024 and
2025.
now this is not a strong forecast and we
still expect a degree of economic slack
to emerge from the end of this year
but the growth Outlook is less weak than
in the NPC's recent projections
recent survey evidence supports this
upward revision consumer confidence
though still weak is at its highest
level for over a year
in the March edition of the bank's nmg
survey households were more optimistic
about the general economic situation
than in the previous survey done last
September
and the bank's network of Agents has
reported that activity has been stronger
recently than their contacts had
previously expected
now above all the Improvement in the
Outlook reflects a further fall in
wholesale gas prices
reversing some of the terms a trade shop
that has been the primary cause of
falling real incomes
but there has also been greater
resilience in the economy than we'd
expected
as seen for example in strong employment
numbers
fiscal policy is also expected to boost
GDP over the forecast built into a
peaking impact of around a half percent
both the temporary 100 Capital
allowances are qualifying business
Investments and measures aimed at
increasing labor market participation
are assumed to have positive effects on
potential Supply
let me turn to the outlook for inflation
annual Consumer Price inflation has come
down from a peak of 11.1 percent in
October last year but it remains very
high
the latest figure of 10.1 for March was
0.8 percentage points higher than we had
expected at the time of the February
report
higher food and clothing prices account
for most of that upside surprise
food inflation has been particularly
High reaching 19.1 percent
and as you can see in chart two
This Is Not Just Happening Here in the
UK
food inflation rates are similar across
Europe
we are acutely aware of how difficult
this rise in food prices is for people
and especially for those people on Lower
incomes
we do see that food price inflation will
start to slow
prices of wholesale agricultural
Commodities have come down since the
spring of last year
and food producer price indices have
eased in recent months
evidence collected by the bank's agents
suggests that food producers expect food
production costs to moderates
while this may take longer than we
previously thought we should expect this
to feed through to consumer food
inflation over the coming year
and I would add that this is what I hear
when I visit and meet with both food
producers and retailers